Quelle est votre nom ? (Auditeur : Howard. Howard.)
Thom Mayne : Howard? Je suis assis à côté d'Howard. Je ne le connais pas, comme vous le voyez,
et il me dit, J'espère que vous n'êtes pas le suivant.
(Rires)
Fascinant. Une démonstration fascinante.
En quelque sorte je me suis vidé la tête à l'écouter.
Mais -- Permettez-moi de démarrer. Je m'intéresse --
Je fais à peu près la même chose, sauf que je ne fais pas bouger mon corps.
Et plutôt que d'utiliser des personnages pour développer des idées sur le temps et l'espace,
je travaille dans le monde minéral. Je travaille plus ou moins avec de la matière inerte.
Et je l'organise. Et, aussi, c'est un peu différent
parce qu'un architecte comparé à, disons, une compagnie de danse
c'est finalement un arbitrage entre son univers personnel,
son monde de concepts, le monde des idées, le monde des aspirations,
des inventions, et sa relation avec le monde extérieur
et toutes les limitations qu'il impose, les grincheux.
Car je dois dire, tout au long de ma carrière,
ce qui a été une constante, c'est que ce n'était pas possible.
Quoi que je fasse, quoi que j'essaie de faire,
tout le monde disait que ce n'était pas possible.
Et c'est une constante tout au long du spectre complet des différents
types de réalités que vous confrontez avec vos idées.
Et être un architecte, parfois c'est devoir arbitrer entre votre gauche et votre droite,
trouver un compromis entre ce lieu intime où naissent vos idées
et le monde extérieur, et rendre tout cela compréhensible.
Je peux démarrer de n'importe où, parce que ce processus est aussi --
je pense -- très différent de celui des conférences du matin,
dans lesquelles on suit une idée, limpide, linéaire
comme la précédente, avec Howard,
tandis que je pense que le processus créatif en architecture,
le processus de design, est extrêmement circulaire. Labyrinthique.
C'est une idée de Calvino que le plus court chemin entre 2 points
est la ligne détournée, et pas la ligne droite.
Et assurément ma vie a été en partie comme cela.
Je vais commencer avec quelques façons simples
que nous avons d'organiser les choses.
Mais typiquement, ce que nous faisons, est de donner une cohérence au monde.
Nous fabriquons des choses physiques, des bâtiments,
qui deviennent une partie du processus d'accrétion, de la fabrication des villes.
Et ces choses sont le reflet de ces processus,
et de la temporalité dans laquelle elles sont faites.
Et ce que j'essaie de faire est de synthétiser la façon dont le monde
et les territoires, qui sont utiles en tant que matériau génératif, sont perçus.
Parce que ce qui m'intéresse, en tant qu'architecte,
est la manière dont les choses sont produites, parce que c'est mon travail.
Et ce n'est pas basé sur un a priori.
Je n'ai pas envie de concevoir quelque chose dans ma tête
et de dire, "Cela ressemble à ça." En fait, quelqu'un a mentionné --
Ewan, je crois que c'était dans votre introduction --
à propos de ce que les architectes --
quelqu'un a dit que c'était là où les hommes d'affaires venaient,
là où le monde des affaires venait
quand ils voulaient que le travail ait l'air complètement fini ? Huh. Waou.
Cela ne marche pas du tout comme cela pour moi.
Cela ne m'intéresse pas du tout.
L'architecture est le commencement de quelque chose, parce que --
si vous ne vous intéressez pas au principes fondamentaux,
à l'absolu,
au commencement de processus génératif, ce que vous faites, c'est de la décoration pour pâtisserie.
Et je -- rien de mal à faire de la décoration de pâtisserie ou à être pâtissier,
si quelqu'un fait de la décoration de pâtisserie --
ce n'est pas ce qui m'intéresse.
Et donc, dans la formation des choses, dans le fait de leur donner une forme, de leur donner --
en concrétisant ces choses,
la notion de départ est celle de l'organisation.
Et pendant 30 ans je me suis intéressé aux complexités
dues à de multiples forces
afin de percer la nature du résultat final,
c'est-à-dire le bâtiment lui-même.
Il y a une relation continue entre les innovations,
qui sont privées, et la réalité, qui est aussi importante pour moi.
Un projet, présenté dans une exposition à Copenhague il y a 10 ans,
la modélisation d'un hippocampe --
la région du cerveau qui enregistre la mémoire à court-terme --
et la production de sa documentation, documentation imaginaire
en une série de dessins qui essaient d'organiser ce phénomène.
Et il y a un lien avec la fait de marcher un kilomètre,
en observant, à chaque kilomètre, un objet particulier du désir,
et en le plaçant sur celui-ci.
Et ainsi j'ai pu créer une organisation
non pas construite sur une cohérence comme on rencontre d'habitude, mais sur des non sequiturs, sur du hasard.
Et je me suis beaucoup intéressé à cette notion de hasard,
en tant qu'elle produit une œuvre architecturale
et qu'elle est clairement connectée à la notion de ville,
à une notion d'accrétion de la ville,
et produit différents concepts d'organisation.
Cela mène à des idées plus générales de constructions
rassemblées par une multiplicité de systèmes.
Et ce n'est pas un seul système qui fait tout le travail.
C'est la relation, c'est la dynamique entre les systèmes,
qui a le pouvoir de transformer et d'inventer
et de produire cette architecture -- qui autrement n'existerait pas.
Et ces systèmes ont pu être définis,
et regroupés.
Et bien sûr, aujourd'hui, avec l'informatique
et le prototypage rapide, etc., nous avons les mécanismes qu'il faut
pour comprendre et répondre à ces systèmes,
et pour leur permettre de s'ajuster aux différentes adaptations des fonctions
parce que c'est notre travail.
Nous produisons des espaces qui s'adaptent à l'activité humaine.
Et ce qui m'intéresse n'est pas leur enjolivement,
mais leur relation, ce qui permet d'amélioration cette activité.
C'est directement lié aux idées d'une élaboration des villes.
Voici un projet que nous venons juste de finir à Penang
un projet pour une très, très grande ville, et qui est le produit direct de ce processus,
le résultat de la multiplicité des forces qui le produisent.
Et le projet -- encore une fois, énorme, énorme concours --
sur la rivière Hudson et à New York
que l'on nous a demandé de faire il y a trois ans, qui utilise ces processus.
Et ce que vous voyez là sont les possibilités liées
à la génération de ville lorsque l'on applique cette méthodologie
qui utilise ces notions de forces multiples,
capable de répondre à l'énormité du problème, à sa complexité,
lorsque l'on dessine des villes et que les ensembles deviennent de plus en plus gros.
Un des problèmes actuels est
que l'ensemble de l'économie guide le développement
et plus la taille des ensembles augmente plus nous avons besoin
de processus de recherche complexes afin de résoudre ces problèmes.
Ce qui nous amène directement au Village Olympique.
J'étais à New York lundi pour une présentation au CIO.
Nous avons gagné la compétition -- quand était-ce, il y a neuf mois ?
Encore, la conséquence directe de l'utilisation de ces processus
pour développer des organismes extrêmement compliqués, à très grande échelle.
Nous travaillons sur des stratégies très générales.
Dans ce cas, nous avons seulement utilisé 6 des 24 hectares de terrain,
les 18 hectares restant pour un parc, qui deviendrait ainsi un héritage du Village Olympique.
Ce qui fait de lui le second parc le plus grand de la ville, etc.
Cette situation, bien sûr, au milieu de Manhattan -- à Hunter's Point.
Et aussi ces idées d'élaboration de villes
commencent à avoir une influence directe sur l'architecture,
sur les éléments qui composent le schéma d'ensemble,
les constructions elles-mêmes, et qui commencent à nous guider.
L'architecture serait pour moi l'analyse d'une multitude de forces
qui pourraient venir littéralement de n'importe où.
Et donc je peux démarrer cette discussion de n'importe où également,
et j'ai choisi trois ou quatre points de départ.
C'est lié également
au vastes domaines que l'architecture touche.
L'architecture est connectée à pratiquement tout, dans le domaine de la connaissance.
Il n'y a aucun domaine qui, d'une certaine manière
n'y soit pas relié.
C'est Jim Dine, et c'est l'absence de la présence, etc.
Le vêtement, la peau, sans la présence du personnage.
C'est devenu une idée de surface pour une œuvre,
utilisée dans un projet où nous avons déroulé cette surface,
une idée figurative, qui serait repliée
dans un espace d'une certaine complexité.
Et l'idée était la relation avec cet espace,
fait de la pliure de l'image,
et la dialectique ou le conflit entre la figuration,
la limpidité de l'image,
et la complexité de l'espace, qui dialoguaient
Et cela nous a fait repenser à notre conception du travail
et comment nous faisons les choses.
ce qui nous a rapproché du stylisme de mode, aplanir les surfaces,
puis les connecter pour qu'elles se combinent spatialement.
Et voici le premier prototype en Corée,
l'enveloppe de ce projet est dynamique,
avec les mêmes propriétés que le tissu.
elle a une identité matérielle, elle est translucide et poreuse,
et nous donne une idée très différente de ce qu'est la surface d'un bâtiment.
c'est devenu très vite un autre projet
Le Caltrans building à Los Angeles.
Nous voyons que la surface et le corps sont différentiés.
C'est une notion très très simple.
Quand vous regardez le plupart des bâtiments,
ce que vous regardez, c'est le bâtiment. La façade, c'est le bâtiment.
Et tout d'un coup on s'éloigne,
et on sépare la surface du corps,
ce qui nous conduit à des critères performances plus généraux,
je vais vous en parler dans un instant.
Et vous voyez comment il se drape
et se différentie du corps.
Et ici, le bâtiment lui-même,
au milieu de Los Angeles, juste en face de l'Hôtel de Ville.
En bougeant, il emmène une partie de la terre avec lui. Il se courbe.
C'est en partie un système de signes,
une sorte d'héritage de Los Angeles --
les signes en deux, trois dimensions, etc.
Ce qui nous permet de pénétrer dans l'œuvre elle-même.
C'est transparent, et cela nous permet de comprendre, je pense,
ce qui est le plus intéressant dans une construction,
c'est-à-dire le processus réel de construction à l'œuvre.
Et c'est probablement le lieu le plus intense
de l'œuvre, qui est inoccupé.
car l'architecture est toujours plus intéressante quand sa mécanique
est séparée de sa fonctionnalité,
l'endroit nous permet de faire ça.
Et puis la surface se transforme en d'autres matériaux.
Dans ce cas, nous utilisons la lumière comme matériau de construction.
Nous travaillons avec Keith Sonnier à New York,
et nous créons ce grand espace extérieur,
ce qui est possible à Los Angeles, et qui reflète
les environnements urbains contemporains
que vous pourriez trouver par exemple à Shibuya ou à Mexico City
ou San Paolo, etc,
du fait que la ville reste plus longtemps active.
Et cela faisait vraiment partie de l'objectif
d'urbanisme de ce projet à Los Angeles.
Et, encore, tout dans ce projet favorise la transparence.
Une image plus parlante à propos de la façon d'utiliser la lumière
la lumière devient vraiment un matériau de construction.
C'est devenu immédiatement beaucoup plus général - et d'une plus grande portée.
Et voici un des premiers croquis
d'où je comprends
que la surface peut être une transition entre le terrain et la tour.
C'est un bâtiment à San Francisco qui est en construction.
C'est devenu un problème beaucoup, beaucoup plus large.
lié à la performance.
C'est le premier bâtiment aux Etats-Unis qui a supprimé --
je ne peux pas dire qu'il a supprimé l'air conditionné. C'est un hybride.
Je voulais quelque chose de pur, et je n'ai pas pu l'avoir.
Ce n'est pas une attitude très positive, en fait l'hybride est plus intéressant.
Et donc nous avons supprimé l'air conditionné de la tour.
Il reste encore de l'air conditionné dans sa base,
mais l'enveloppe est mobile, montée sur hydrauliques.
Ce qui fait passer l'air -- grâce à l'effet Venturi si il n'y a pas de vent.
Cela s'ajuste en permanence. Et nous avons enlevé l'air conditionné.
C'est quelque chose d'énorme, énorme. Un delta de quatre cent mille euros par an.
10 comme ça -- cela fait un peu moins de 100 000 mètres carrés --
80000 mètres carrés et quelque --
10 comme ça pourraient fournir Sausalito en électricité -- le delta.
Ce que nous voyons, c'est que plus les projets gagnent en taille,
plus ils deviennent -- s'interfaçant avec de plus larges problèmes,
ils augmentent leurs possibilités
en termes de performance.
Et sinon, je pourrais aussi partir d'ici.
Je pourrais vous parler de la relation
en termes plus biologiques, de la relation avec le bâtiment et le sol.
Bien, nos recherches -- celles de ma génération évidemment,
ceux qui allaient à l'école fin des années 60 --
se sont fortement distanciées de cette façon de considérer l'architecture,
de ce regard de l'architecture vers elle-même,
et nous avons été très influencés par le cinéma,
par ce qu'il se passait dans le monde de l'art, etc.
Il s'agit, bien sûr, de Michael Heizer.
Et quand j'ai vu cela, d'abord en image puis lorsque je l'ai visité,
ça a complètement changé ma manière de penser après ça.
Et j'ai compris que la construction pouvait être vraiment
un agrandissement de la surface de la Terre,
et ça a complètement modifié la notion de terrain de construction dans son sens le plus basique.
Et voilà -- il a probablement vu ça -- c'est Nazca,
cela date de 700 ans -- les sculptures les plus fascinantes, sur une étendue de 4 kilomètres.
C'est totalement incroyable.
Et cela nous a fait repenser complètement notre façon de dessiner, notre façon de travailler.
Ceci est le premier croquis d'un lycée à Pomona.
Et bien, quoi que cela puisse être, c'est un modèle, une sorte d'idée conceptuelle.
Il s'agit de remodeler la terre de manière à la rendre occupable.
Cela prend 19,000 mètres carrés de matière pour créer un lycée
sur la surface de la terre.
Là il est modelé de la manière que le serait une œuvre d'art.
Et ici, le problème architectural est en train d'être résolu,
et là voici le lycée.
Et, bien sûr, ce qui nous intéresse --
nous voulons être un élément du système éducatif.
Je n'ai absolument pas envie de produire un bâtiment
qui répond seulement à une fonction X, Y ou Z.
Ce qui m'intéresse, c'est comment ces idées
participent au processus éducatif des jeunes.
Cela nécessite une recherche
parce que ce système s'est développé en dehors de toute sculpturalité.
Cette idée est partie de mon première sujet.
Elle a à faire avec une logique générale, assez cohérente,
et cette logique peut être comprise lorsque l'on occupe le bâtiment.
Et il y a une grande ouverture -- tout au moins,
on tente de créer une notion très ouverte d'un bâtiment
connecté à la terre de différentes manières
parce que je voulais avoir une approche très didactique du problème
comme on peut le comprendre.
Et le second projet qui venait de se terminer à Los Angeles
est construit sur la même idée. Il utilise le paysage comme idée majeure.
Ici, encore, nous faisons le siège du NOAA (ANOA) --
Agence Nationale d'Océanographie et de l'Atmosphère --
en dehors de Washington dans le Maryland.
Et c'est ainsi qu'ils voient le monde.
Ils ont 22 satellites qui se déplacent à plus ou moins 100 miles (160 kilomètres),
et le site est en rouge.
Et ce que nous voulons vraiment faire -- nous, les architectes,
si il y a des architectes parmi nous, voici la hutte de Laugier
C'est une hutte primitive, que l'on connaît depuis longtemps.
Et nous voulions construire ça
parce qu'ils se voient comme les gardiens du monde,
et nous voulions qu'ils se regardent de leurs satellites,
qu'ils voient leur propre site, leurs 3 hectares
et rien d'autre. Nous voulions que cela reste vert.
Il y a en fait 3 terrains de baseball,
et ils vont rester là.
Nous plaçons une pièce nord-sud directement,
qui supporte les antennes, d'accord ?
Et juste en dessous le traitement, le monte-charge
et le poste de commande de la mission, et tous les autres espaces sont sous terre.
Et ce que vous voyez là est un porte-avions
dont la performance est liée au cône de vision de ces antennes satellites.
Et le bâtiment lui-même est occupé dans la partie basse,
morcelé par une série de cours,
c'est 2 hectares d'étendue horizontale ininterrompue
pour les bureaux de l'administration.
Et cela, en retour, nous a propulsé vers
des projets de plus grande envergure, où l'interface entre le paysage et le bâtiment
devient un tissu conjonctif.
La compétition pour la nouvelle capitale à Berlin, il y a 4 ans.
Et ici, nous venons de finir la BCE --
Coop Himmelblau à Vienne vient de remporter le projet,
le bâtiment y était coupé par des éléments du paysage
qui sont devenus une partie du tissu conjonctif d'un parc,
qui est parallèle à la rivière et donne des idées pour le bâtiment lui-même,
et devient une part du tissu de connexion --
le social, le culturel, et le paysage, et tissu récréationnel de la ville.
Le bâtiment n'est plus quelque chose d'autonome,
mais inextricablement connecté
à la ville et cet endroit à ce moment
Et ce projet réalisé en Autriche, la banque Hooper,
qui prend cette idée de typologie connective,
les bâtiments traditionnels, et la morphologie,
ou l'idée de transformation de la terre
en un complexe qui est un morceau de la ville par lequel on la voit
littéralement s'agrandir.
Ce type de mouvement de terre, c'est l'idée très simple
de la soulever et de l'occuper,
et d'autre parties sont beaucoup plus énergiques et intenses.
Je peux parler de cette intensité
produite par des collisions d'évènements
liés au fait d'assembler une série de systèmes,
et le sol en est une partie, et les élévations en opposition une autre partie.
L'une pénètre dans le bâtiment tout en s'élevant au-dessus du sol,
et devient une partie de cette idée.
Et la surface -- sa limite en quelque sorte --
tout cela produit la dynamique, le mouvement du bâtiment
à la façon d'une série de mouvements sismiques, géologiques, n'est-ce pas ?
Et cela crée de l'espace pour les évènements et se morcelle à des endroits
qui permettent de scruter l'intérieur, et ces intérieurs-là, une fois encore,
favorisent la transparence du lieu de travail,
ce qui a été continuellement pour nous un cheval de bataille.
Et ici, encore, dans un cadre plus traditionnel,
c'est un logement étudiant à Toronto,
et il s'agit ici du concept d'un bâtiment
en ce qu'il crée une connexion avec la ville.
L'idée principale était l'entrée, où le site se termine,
et le bâtiment occupe à la fois l'espace public et l'espace privé.
Et ceci est le territoire -- le voici.
J'ai visité ce site de nombreuses fois, et rencontré tout le monde, quasiment --
vous pouvez voir ça d'une distance de deux kilomètres comme le centre exact de la rue,
et le concept entier est d'engager le public,
d'utiliser les bâtiments comme une part du réseau public de la ville.
Et enfin, l'un des projets les plus intéressants -- un tribunal.
Et ce dont je voulais parler -- c'est la Cour Suprême, bien sûr --
et, donc, je travaille avec Michael Hogan, le président de la cour d'Oregon.
Vous ne pouvez pas travailler sans faire ces compromis
entre vos propres valeurs et celles
de la personne avec laquelle vous travaillez, et l'idée qu'il se fait du tribunal
parce que je lui montre, bien sûr, Le Corbusier à la Villa Savoy,
on est en 1928, le début de l'architecture moderne.
Et nous arrivons à cette image.
Le projet a démarré d'ici. Parce que vais,
Je m'intéresse au phénomène qui se produit ici.
Et vraiment ce dont nous parlons est de construire la réalité.
Et je suis quelqu'un d'extrêmement intéressé
par la comprendre la nature de cette réalité construite
parce que la nature en tant que telle n'existe plus. La Nature n'est plus.
Je parle de la Nature au sens du XIXème siècle, d'accord ?
La Nature est une construction culturelle aujourd'hui, non ?
Nous la construisons et nous construisons ces idées.
Et bien sûr, celle ci, notre gouverneur actuel.
Et nous avons passé du temps avec Conan, croyez-moi,
ce qui a mis au jour les différences fondamentales entre nos deux mondes
d'un point de vue légal, artistique et architectural.
Et nous avons été amené à parler de la façon dont nous concevons notre travail,
et de sa dynamique, et de ses sources.
Et cela a conduit au projet, au tribunal,
ce qui est tout à fait le fruit d'un compromis
entre la tradition et les éléments qui composent un tribunal traditionnel.
Il y a un escalier de la même longueur que celui de la Cour Suprême.
Voici un piano nobile, qui était utilisé à la Renaissance.
Les cours de justice étaient faites comme cela. La surface est faite de cette série de strates.
qui rappellent de la maçonnerie rustique
mais avec des fragments de la Constitution enchâssés,
qui sont une partie d'un procédé,
posé sur une plinthe qui la présente devant la communauté.
Merci beaucoup.
(Applaudissements)